she's the chief financial officer of one
of the biggest telecommunications
equipment companies in the world
now it's emerged that mangwon Zhu has
been in custody in Canada for days US
authorities appear to be seeking her
extradition on charges of helping kwame
violate the US trade embargo against
Iran further details of the allegations
against her are still unknown but her
arrest comes at faraway faces increasing
scrutiny from abroad in the past US
lawmakers have described the company as
a threat to national security
saying it's technology could be used for
spying other countries like Australia
and New Zealand share those concerns and
have found huawei's equipment from being
used in their high-speed 5g mobile
networks Huawei has repeatedly denied
those claims when news of Meg's arrest
broke
China's Embassy in Canada released a
statement saying it firmly opposes and
strongly protests the move the arrest
comes at an especially sensitive time in
u.s. Chinese trade relations last
weekend the country's leaders agreed to
a 90 day truce in their months long
trade dispute the u.s. decision to
target one of China's most important
tech giant's is only likely to reignite
tensions let's get the very latest on
the story now and bring in DW Asia
business correspondent Linda Hong
joining us from Singapore Linda what's
behind the accusations that mang Washu
violated US sanctions against Iran well
has been ongoing since around April
already when the sanctions has actually
been probing US authorities has been
probing Huawei which is the world's
largest telecom equipment maker for
allegedly shipping us everything
products for Iran and other countries in
violation of US exports and sanction
laws so they have actually been
investigating this case and this issue
for quite a while already okay it's not
just the United States a number of
Western secret services accused telecoms
giant wall way of spying for the Chinese
government what did they say
has been doing well they are actually
saying that because Farley is actually
pretty closely connected with the
government pic note that the founder who
is moving Joe's father is actually a
former officer of the People's
Liberation Army as well as an elected
member of the Communist Party so there's
quite closely relations and this has got
to do with your politics and take the
hallway actually has got a lot of money
to develop 5g Network so we all know
that 5g is the upcoming wireless network
and quo is also one of the largest ones
so there's actually quite a bit of
concern that while we might actually be
having doing some so-called spying for
so for China on the rest of the other
government okay now what have been the
reactions in Beijing to this arrest and
and how that's going to affect trade and
tariffs well she's been kind of tensions
that we have actually seen shoes but
second of all we have actually fallen
after this news it's very much to do
with our face as well on behalf of the
Chinese government they actually need to
have discussions and negotiations with
the US on the clean slate and this has
actually sort of sparked a bit of
tension or reunited tensions definitely
going to be in high tensions of both
sides particularly for Chinese are
because business actually that there's
actually no confirmation or details on
the charges of what she's being charged
with
so there's definitely going to be
reigniting of this trade tensions going
forward
GWS Linda Hong for us and Singapore
thanks very much